all right pretty yes sir pretty uh where
are you from originally where'd you grow
up I'm from Cape Verde Africa
um most people have never heard of is a
small country 10 Islands west coast of
Africa but then I immigrated to Boston
when I was about seven years old so I
would like to say that I grew up in
Boston
but I'm still very tapped in with my
culture Cape Verde
you had mom and dad I do I'm very close
with them
um
mom got remarried when I was like two
and Dad
's rock and roll
he's in the U.S or currently right now
he's back home in Cape Verde
um
I think my dad has like probably 14 kids
and my mom has three
but I'm close with both of them like my
siblings like to think that my father's
favorite I like to think that too if you
ask me how was your childhood my
childhood was uh you know I grew up in a
three Decker
um house in Dorchester Massachusetts and
on each floor was an uncle and Aunt so
it was like big family you know the 90s
just a lot of before the technology I
feel like family was more united
so there was a lot of that weekend Vibes
and stuff of such
how fresh you at school
I went as far as College didn't graduate
dropped out went to college to kind of
make my mom be quiet like your sons made
it
and that was a show
but now I'm currently in school what did
you want to do with your life
what did I wanted to do with my life uh
if you when I was so real quick I I
lived in New York for a little bit with
my uncle he was a bishop he's a bishop
and at that time when I was under his
care my dream was to be a bishop or a
pastor
but that changed
you know
um
I don't know
that changed and then for one point my
dream was to be the El Chapo of
Dorchester
has changed a lot is that the direction
your life kind of took yeah that's the
direction of my life kind of took
um
I I think I by the age of when I was
like maybe
16 I had to move back to Boston and
um
I like to feel like I looked up to the
dope boys there was this one particular
guy I'll never forget
um my brother had a shop my brother
Peter had a shop and this guy became his
partner and he had a Cadillac Escalade
and it just wow
um and that draw me towards him and
eventually he introduced me to a
lifestyle I started
um at early age I think I was in high
school I got into fake money uttering
um hundred dollar bills what they was
doing we were bleaching five dollar
bills and scan printing 100 bills on it
so you get right through with the pen
check and everything
and so in high schools already making
good good amount of money
um that didn't last too long I ended up
picking up a case from that I was the
first one that they had caught with that
money so from Boston to Florida they had
tracked about
two million dollars and I was the first
one that they caught with that money
um but I just went to buy some stuff at
the store and after I left
they tracked the plates of the car and
the girl that had rented me the car
called me like what did you do I'm like
what are you talking about the feds
already had swarmed her mom's house her
brother ended up getting locked up
it was bad
you know
um
that case my family
um hired one of the best lawyers
and for what it was I think I got a slap
on the risk and it was my first case so
it was nothing you know
I was still in high school it was for
counterfeiting counterfeiting uttering
they call it that's the real word
[Music]
you know
but you got another stuff too yeah I
definitely got into other stuff quickly
as well uh I got into the weed game
that went well for a while and then
um little by little I just always think
big and big and bigger and a good friend
of mine we'll call him t
was going to Miami and he said let's
take a drive out there and we took a
drive to Miami within a day we end up
walking into some Cuban connects and
then
now at this point we're trafficking
marijuana
and other type of drugs into Boston it
was three of us in the car
I was with two felon friends of mine and
I didn't have no license I was not even
an American citizen then and we are 95.
28 hours from Boston to Miami pick up
drive back down
now that I think about it I was
courageous because I could have faced
deportation if I had got caught up
but you know you're young you have this
dream and the dream is to be this big
successful drug dealer so you're gonna
you're gonna put your all into it and I
feel like that's what
I started doing at a very early age I
was not even 20 when I started doing
this thing
and that turned me into a person like I
built a Persona around me
I had this image of I get money and I'm
rock and roll so I was in the nightclubs
Thursday to Sunday a lot of women and
there was just this image you know this
was when Lil Wayne was out I was a big
fan of Wayne my cousin Tito named me
pretty when I had moved from New York
and then when Wayne came around he used
to call himself I believe Weezy F baby
so I became pretty F baby and it was a
whole Persona image around it it was
good for a while you know
um and then I had got into a motorcycle
accident when I was in vacation in Cape
Verde and when I came back to America I
had surgery
um that was probably like 2006 and the
doctor sent home a 17 year old I had
Vicodins and I had perks and I don't
like to point the fingers at anybody on
how my life went because America didn't
have the knowledge that they have today
on opiate and that started something in
my life it opened something in my brain
because
the feeling that I got from that pill
it was a feeling that I never had and I
never thought was possible it's as if I
found the magic pill
I was always comfortable myself
it my ego was boosted I could talk to
any girl I can do anything I felt like
I'm like Superman once I take this pill
and little by little you know
I would Dibble and Dabble and next thing
you know I'm catching myself going to
the ER lying about back pain
and then having one of my girls go and
lie about back pain and like I said then
America did not have the knowledge you
go to the ER where the back pain they'll
send you home with 512s about 15 script
15 pills
um fast forward the I end up getting my
feet deeper and deeper into the drug
game
and
um
at my highest point
I would be able to sell about a thousand
per 30s at a time
like it went fast
we would go to Miami
and Miami had the pain clinics MRI these
are stuff that's all Google
um you could Google and find all this
information out you would get an MRI
um go to pain clinic and then you get a
script for 30 milligrams now you do that
with about eight different people
you flying them out you're doing all
that it's like legally trafficking
I had a saying that
um
how did it go
I did the wrong things the right way
you know you're getting on a plane
and a girl has a script with her name on
it you're going through TSA it's like
taking candy from a kid
um but with that my addiction started
progressing
and it progressed it took a long time it
took about I for me to go uh
there was a point where if I had a perk
on a Monday I'm like oh I'm going
clubbing on Thursday I could just leave
it on top of my account and not touch it
but eventually you want that feeling all
the time and then it went from being
able to save a perk to not being able to
start my day without a 30.
so
um when that started happening
I was good with all of it because I was
able to afford my addiction you know and
then
um things you know the FED started
cracking down on the pain clinics in
Miami
and
you start dealing with other people you
start dealing with other people and I
was getting packages still getting the
30s the prices had went up and still
getting 30 and then one particular time
I had got a batch the things looked
funny
but whatever when I took it I started
throwing up
and then I'm like what is this but then
I got super high it's like I'm getting
that feeling on perks but on steroids
and I didn't really like it but I
enjoyed the high I didn't like the side
effects of it the throwing up because it
was very strong but I kept doing it and
then my connect ended up sending me
another batch
that I ended up taking I think two it
didn't touch me
it was two perk 30s it didn't touch me
ended up taking like another four it
didn't touch me I think all together
within a Spam of an hour I took like
maybe 12 per 30s didn't touch me
I remember I had gave a kid
um a few of those bad ones and I said if
he had him he said yeah I went back and
switched it and come to find out
those was the perk 30s that was pressed
with fentanyl you know counterfeit perks
and that began something that
[Music]
that began
something that made me lose my morals
that began something that made me strip
for myself
that began something that I today I'm
able to identify as an addict
that began
it that
made me
become a person I no longer knew who I
was
the counterfeit 30s
it opened something else in me
you know
um
I mean I'm going really fast but you
know
I was a married man
you know
um
I was a man that
always dressed well very well spoken
very well known in the community
regardless of the lifestyle I lived and
what I did for a living but I was not
like this big gangster dude or anything
I got money in the streets I hung around
with the gangsters but
so I always kept a good image for myself
I mean in Brockton Massachusetts I was
friends with the mayor
I frequent restaurants in the Cape
Verdean community that I knew everyone
the fentanyl stripped me from all of
that
I am a divorced man today
because of fentanyl
and the thing with fentanyl is so
dangerous because you keep compromising
you keep going lower and lower and lower
uh I'm not an addict because
I don't
shoot it
I'm not an addict because I don't smoke
it
I'm not an addict because
I'm not stealing I'm able to afford my
high
so you just keep
um negotiating with yourself
almost to kind of give yourself that
that reasoning for why you're doing the
things you're doing
towards the end
am I low point
I have an uncle Chalet
and he was the one person that
no matter what you know you have those
family members that they're not
knowledgeable with addiction so they
become an enabler unintentionally this
is what this Uncle was to me
towards the end
he was the one person that was housing
me I didn't become homeless in the
streets
per se because of my family's ego you
know what is the people going to say
but I was a homeless man I didn't have a
place of my own
and that one person that was housing me
at this point I used to smoke cigarettes
he would buy me a pack of cigarettes
every day
because of my addiction with fentanyl
I started stealing from him to get my
fix
so all those things that I said I
wouldn't be
little by little I ended up opening that
side of me
and
you get to this low point in your life
that
when you look back at the lifestyle that
had made for myself the name I had made
for myself
and
you look back
and you ask yourself how did I get here
it's so much easier looking on the
outside like it was the doctor's fault
or it was the connect fault or it's
these people's fault
I don't know whose fault it was
I really don't
I just know
that
um
I wanted help and I didn't know how to
get out
I became suicidal
because of fentanyl
and I was a person I enjoyed life I was
life of the party I was a person that
traveled I go back home to my Country
Cape Verde and I'm life of the party I'm
a people person
um that magic thing that I talk about
that I got from The Perks it made me
more sociable
um
Fentanyl
made me isolate
it gave me that same feeling that I
would get from a perks but on steroid
but it came with a hefty price
in my deepest addiction I didn't take
showers for four or five maybe six days
I'm the type of person you couldn't pay
me enough to drink from someone's cup
that they already drank on
I didn't shower for like days
I no longer cared about my the way I
looked
the best way I could put I became a
slave
to fentanyl
and well my master called
I answered I didn't care what cost
[Music]
oh fentanyl
it
it took everything for me
everything
I'm the type of person when I walk into
a nightclub the owner knew who I was
I'm the type of person that's very well
connected
I'm the type of person that a family
wouldn't make any major purchase without
consulting with me
cars houses they wouldn't without
because of fentanyl these same family I
was no longer allowed in the house that
I consulted them in purchasing I was no
longer allowed to even use their cars
that's what fentanyl did
you know
um it stripped me from
from society
um
in that thing that I talk about that I'm
not an addict because I don't still
I started stealing towards the end
so how am I not an addict
I am an addict
um
because my behaviors
my morals
was done for
I've overdosed over three times from
Fentanyl
I'm at one particular time my mother was
trying to help me
because you know I don't come from a
family that addiction is a common thing
I don't come
from a place where people are
knowledgeable on even how to help
someone like that you know so my mom
flew from Cape Verde
to her son's Aid how can I help my son
went to a friend's house her friend's
house and we called the detox and this
detox said well we're kind of full but
if you go to the hospital across the
street
they basically gave me hope go to the
hospital shows you really want it will
take you in through the hospital
so me and mom went to the hospital I
remember there was a little bit line I
went into the restroom I came back out I
did a line of Fentanyl
and I overdosed in my Mom's arm in that
line
I can't even begin with to imagine what
that woman
went through in that
second or minutes watching her son just
collapse
fentanyl so
I was such a slave to it that when they
revised me with Narcan
I noticed I still had my socks on
I went back to the bathroom winning my
socks got a fentanyl did another line
you see I was a type that I attempted to
stop
but I'm the type of addict that when I
start I can't stop
and if I stop I couldn't stay stopped
that's the type of person
I became because of my addiction
Fentanyl
it takes everything from you
and I wasn't in a low point in my life
that I didn't even think
that I would be able to pull myself out
of that situation because of Fentanyl
and then you know in the beginning I was
able to try to maintain an image
somewhat
buy-in from people like yeah these are
for my runners you know these are for
whatever and then it went from me being
able to buy 200 grams
to at that low point two and a half gram
the type of
drug daylight was people knew that I'm
not buying no two and a half grand for
one of my runners
um
I remember an early addiction
my ex-wife would look into my eyes with
my son in her arms
pretty can you just stop for us
I would look at her and tell her yeah
and I wasn't lying
there was something
in me that just couldn't let go of
Fentanyl
and I had a
I had a wife that was supportive of a
lot of things
you know
um
she's brought me to detox
she's picked me up from detox with my
pills
but that's not what she signed up for
when she noticed that I'm keep going
lower and lower
I wasn't giving her any hope
she finally said she was done
because of my ego
like what if people in the community
gonna say
I end up like
going back to Cape Verde
I'm done there's no opiates in Cape
Verde I'm good
um but I did go with fentanyl of course
I went about 40 grams and that lasted me
about a month
but and then I end up getting some
Suboxone from some people out here they
sent it to me
and I was good I ended up detoxing
myself and I was good so now I'm on the
island
um
living the good life
drinking
a little cocaine
look at this Molly all I did was
substitute one thing for another
my mom my mother came to me like what do
you want to do with your life I'm like
what are you talking about Ma
she was like people in our country will
give a left arm
to immigrate to America you letting go
America to come be here
I was embarrassed
of the mess I had left behind
you know people's gonna say that my
ex-wife used me for papers because I had
married her and brought her to America
you know so I was always the victim you
know
um
so I didn't want to face that music
so I continued staying in Cape Verdean
let's just say I I was doing things in
Cape Verde that was a little bit too big
for my Island
and I come from very well-known family
so my mom's like you have to stop this
this can't continue going this way this
is not America my stepfather is a lawyer
you know my mom's a very well-known
woman
you know so I finally decided to come
back to America here I was separated
from fentanyl from a year and no opiates
took about
four days
I had did a
fake perk
of course with fentanyl in it in the
Xanax
after I had sniffed cocaine the whole
night
the way my mind worked it's like the
only reason I did that cocaine because
I'm gonna have a reason to have to come
down that reason is
my weakness Fentanyl
I went out after I did that perk 30 well
the fentanyl pill and the Xanax
I was with my friend my childhood best
friend June
he didn't know what was going on he
doesn't understand that thing
he for him I was just sleeping
and then he started smacking me he
noticed that I'm not sleeping
and
he panicked
try to wake me up couldn't wake up
he carried me from the second floor
apartment and put me in the car and
drove me to Boston Medical Center
when I woke up I'm like
how did I get here
the doctor said that it was a miracle I
hadn't had that oxygen in my brain for
like 35 minutes
family members calling what's going on
oh no uh make up lies
make up lies I didn't my brother Peter
had gave me an opportunity to work with
him in his company
he owns a moon bouncing company
and he also
um
does Airbnb in Boston and he gave me the
keys to the airbnbs I'll go clean it
like opportunity was given to me but
because I had this addiction nothing I
touched can ever turn into anything good
I lost my brother's Trust
I was using drugs in one of the airbnbs
so it's so easy for when I was in that
deep addiction for me to be the victim
but I was never the victim
because my family all tried and tried
and tried
you know
and then you would think that
it's because someone comes from a broken
home
that they ended up on drugs or didn't
have the support
or the trauma
yeah that could be because they might be
escaping from that
I don't have the answers to why
because I was some kid
brought up in
a home grandparents in the house that
90s love you know a lot of people coming
over
ended up here
so
I don't like to point their fingers
because my own qualities taught me that
when you point the fingers you have
three pointing back at you
but in my addiction I point to my whole
hands because I was the victim
[Music]
low Point twin size mattress on the
floor in my uncle's one bedroom
apartment in Brockton Massachusetts
stealing money from him to get a fix
not taking a shower
not able to afford cigarettes
my uncle Bishop Angelo came from New
York this is doing kovid it was kind of
weird for you to see people come visit
you like what are you doing here like
everyone was the enemy he sat me down he
said
I can't watch you throw your life away
like this anymore
God has a plan for you
he's like I spoke to some people in
Phoenix Arizona there's a program there
you go there for a year
[Music]
I was so
I was willing
to do anything at this point
I took that
when I went to Phoenix Arizona
the program was not a good fit for me
my childhood best friend that I
mentioned earlier June Freedom he lives
in California
and you know being an addict I know how
to manipulate coming from the lifestyle
I've come from I know how to maneuver
and get people to think what I want them
to think
and I called them I said my family sent
me to this place is a cult
this Statin III he's like bro you're not
an addict like those people
I said you're right I'm not an addict
like those people he's like you don't
need rehab I said I don't he said you
are an hour flight from California he's
like you are a hustler you'll stay with
me for three days and you'll figure it
out
I am a hustler
because of fentanyl I didn't have no
more hustle in me
I remember I went to Denny's
end up meeting the random person
and I asked him for some perks and he
said like this and I seen five blue
thirties the fake ones
I grabbed that and I grabbed probably
another 10.
booked my flight
told my family they are the enemy I am
done with them how can they send me to
that place
I'm coming to California I had never
been to California before
June picked me up at the airport
and everything he picked me up him and
him in Chanel
and everything was good you know I had a
little bit of money
um I had put some money away
so you know when you have that some type
of financial cushion you kind of like
don't even pay attention to your
addiction because I'm able to afford it
[Music]
I had never scored drugs before because
in Boston I was
a well-connected individual
I started walking June's dog within an
hour of me being in his apartment
go come back
I was walking the dog every three hours
it took June 24 hours to find out the
extent of my addiction that I am a
full-blown Junkie
I came through like a thunderstorm he
was getting ready to release his music
and there was it was it was just bad
timing
and his main focus was me
um I was supposed to stay with June for
three days and then get her Airbnb for a
month
because I'm a hustler figure it out
and then I ended up connecting with a
cousin that I didn't even know
um
was out here but I knew she kind of
might have been out here Anika and I
told her you know
I lied by a mission my our family sent
me to Phoenix Arizona to go change my
life
he's like
our family why would they do that like I
don't know they sent me to a place
that's a cult it's like what's your plan
um at June I'm gonna get an Airbnb for a
month and figure out oh no none of my
cousin my family's coming to California
he's like I haven't and she said I have
an in-law apartment in the back you
could stay here
right there all my problems got removed
no longer had to worry about getting the
place oh to top it off she gave me a key
to a 2020. BMW X5
I was big chilling
it took Anika
about four days to find out something is
wrong
with her cousin
and little by little one day I remember
I pulled up to the house I had just did
a Xanax and um a fentanyl pill
right before I hopped off the highway
and then all I can remember is waking up
with the car running and I looked at the
clock it was like four o'clock in the
morning
my cousin Anika's in her robe like
what's going on
oh no
um I fell asleep
you know
just
afraid
of what she's gonna think for me to open
up and say I'm on drugs and I'm strong
now so you just keep lying and lying and
lying and lying
my good friend June
um had met an individual
and he remembered that that individual
had been sober for 33 years
June called him up
and
he said sure bring this guy over
I go over
the guy started talking to me into a
language that I finally understood
it's a person that had been through what
I've been through
at first I'm thinking I'm going okay
whatever
he said you have to go to detox you have
to do this you have to do that
I said okay
my back was against the wall I had no
more hustle left in me
I'm across country I had never been to
California
I'm my cousin Anika's basically done
with me if I don't get this right
my back was against the wall
and
I took that option
I went to detox I went to detox I don't
even know where
I woke up the next morning like how did
I get here
fentanyl withdrawal I don't wish it upon
my worst enemy
diarrhea nauseous
you don't want to eat you want to crawl
out of your skin
and all you could think of that there is
something out there that can fix this
like this
that's all you could think of no matter
what the nurses is telling you honey is
gonna be okay
you just know that there's something
there out there which is fat and all
that can make all that disappear
I managed to tug it out
and then
I went
to the rehab that my mentor the guy he
ended up actually being my mentor today
that June Freedom brought me to Gill
suggested I go
I went to a place called Chabad
in Miracle Mile
but I was always used to doing things my
way
I had some challenges as a client at
Chabad the first two months
it's a three-month program
so once
you remove the drugs you remove the
alcohol
you still have this person
that has put a lot of things in the
Pandora box
for years
now all these feelings emotions is
coming up
my family is not talking to me because I
left
the place that they sent me to go get
saved
my mother's in Cape Verde Africa
I'm across country
so I have all these feelings coming up
and I have to deal with these feelings
and I the one way I know how to deal
with these feelings is that magic pill
but that was no longer an option at
least then
because you start
I had a bird's eye view of my life
when I was in rehab
I see it clearly where and how I ended
up where I ended up at
and it's something I didn't want to go
back to
how do you go being how do you go from
being the most popular kid in high
school
what did 50 Cent say
damn homie in high school you was the
man homie what happened to you homie
fentanyl made me feel like that line was
written for me
scrolling through Facebook watching
people that you went to high school with
become homeowners
married businesses
here I am in California in a rehab
and then you would
hear people's stories
and that they've been sober for five
years
ten years and how much better life has
gotten
start to have some type of Hope
because I know it's there
I know what happens once I touch
fentanyl
but I've never experienced hair
this sobriety thing that people speak of
I've never experienced it I've attempted
it a few times but my definition of
sobriety consisted of detox go home I
just thought I was never good enough so
I always fell back into it I just
thought that's how it was
looking back
the drugs are really never my problem
it was a solution
I was escaping from something still
don't know what I was escaping for by
the way
but I knew I was escaping from something
I did four months in rehab and then they
suggested
sober living
I went to sober living what is it I
don't I didn't know
you have curfew you go to work
you do this you do that you you wait for
them
looking back
it's teaching me how to live again and
live a normal life it's something that I
didn't know what it was a normal life no
more life is get money
travel beautiful woman
no more life today
is completely different
than what I thought normal life was
I've been sober two years in seven
months
from fentanyl
from any mind altering substance
thoroughly sober
a lot of people ask me how I did it or
because those that eat the
have family or personally are affected
by fentanyl nose is nothing easy
so they're always interested in how I
did it
because of fentanyl whatever I touched
led to destruction my ways of doing
things led to destruction doesn't matter
what I touched
I attract I attempted to
um
live a legitimate life back in December
2019 I ended up manipulating my
um
indeed application I end up getting a
job as the account general manager at
Logan International Airport when I throw
on that suit I'm a dangerous individual
um
I oversaw over 100 employees
because of my addiction that was
stripped for me within like a month and
a half
so it didn't matter what I touched
it always equal to nothing
I'm across country I don't got
a family I can like go on their couch I
don't
my back was against the wall I started
taking Direction
I finally came to the conclusion that my
way would not never and would not work
I live a lifestyle that I never began to
imagine
you tell someone
what would you want your life to look
like how would you want your house what
kind of car you would want I was like oh
I want a mansion with a pool
I want a Ferrari why because they've
seen it either movie or in passing
I have a life that I never dreamed of
a sanity
that's what I mean not the materialistic
stuff
the Peace of Mind
when I lay my head down and a pillow
I pray in yala I'm good I could be able
to fall asleep
I didn't have that
I think since I lived in New York with
my uncle
maybe when I was like 14 was the last
time I had that my mind
it was like Jackie Chan and Bruce Lee
was always playing fighting up there
because of sobriety
I have that
fentanyl has brought me to places
I would even go without a pistol
sobriety has brought me to places I
never even dreamed of
I work in the industry now
I freelance I um I do intensive
therapeutic session
in different rehabs different iops
different detoxes
people tell me that they inspired by me
[Music]
the life I dreamed of
to meet El Chapo Dorchester people
looked up to me for all the wrong
reasons
I meet clients
that this is one particular guy Humberto
he did like 23 years
in jail
he was a pretty high-ranking guy in a
gang in jail
when I met him in detox
because of the drugs he couldn't stay up
for more than 15 seconds
without falling asleep I believe he was
on meth
little by little I see I started seeing
this individual
get better and better
and I would and when I go into my
session I tell my clients there's no
difference between you and I I really
mean that I am them they are me
and
this individual today eight months sober
Works in rehab
that's how I do it I stay with those
type of people their story they tell me
that my story inspired them watching
their growth inspire me to continue
going
and there's a lot of stories like his
because I see myself in them in that low
point
and I strongly believe
A wise man once told me that he got to
23 years sobriety because
he let go of one thing so he could have
everything
I believe today if I touch one thing
I will lose everything
I don't want to lose this peace of mind
I have today
but I do say I only have today
and then tomorrow I'll try again with
this sobriety thing
I just show up every day
my mother hadn't seen me for about three
years
my mother traveled
to America
and then traveled to California to come
see this version of her son
that's sobriety
the last image my mom has of me is me on
that twin size mattress in my uncle's
one bedroom apartment with my dirty
clothes all in the back cornered
I don't live in no Mansion I don't have
no luxury apartment
I have a one bedroom apartment
that's from legal money
it's under my name
it's not under my mother's name it's not
under some girl's name
my name
I always had these things but it was all
manipulated
my mentor turned to my mother and asked
her how do you feel to see your son like
this
[Music]
she said it's have this it's has if I'm
not dreaming and I'm waiting for someone
to wake me up and tell me your son
pretty is not doing this good that's not
him
I am a parent
but I will never understand how it is to
love like a mother does
I wouldn't know what it is to hurt
like a mother hurt when they see their
loved ones
going through that and they cannot help
them
[Music]
I don't know how my mother slept that
night knowing that
I was living the way I was living
[Music]
I call my mother now every day
my mom's my best friend my darkest
secret is with that woman
I haven't gone back to Cape Verde yet
since sobriety
friends and family members since I've
been in sobriety
tell me that my mom has a glow to her
it's like wow
our addiction take a toll on our loved
ones that we don't even understand
like
those relationships that I spoke about
family those trust I lost
it's been earned again
when I go back home to Boston it's a
fight which one of them is going to host
me which one of them is going to give me
their car keys
this junkie right here
is a life coach to a Hollywood actor
the guy's not even an addict
it's funny how me and Brandon Met his
name is Brandon Brandon T Jackson
we was in a parking lot he comes up to
me he's like hey you look like nipsy
Hustle
I'm like you look like Brandon T Jackson
he said I am Brandon T Jackson and
that's what started a relationship
to where he I wasn't sober living then
he saw my growth little by little
to where he was inspired by he said I
want what you have I'm like what is that
he's like the discipline
I'm in college
to get my kdac
in 2019 I had a kid that
you know when I was towards the end I
had no more hustle I still was able to
grab a few stuff I gave this kid
fentanyl to push for me
because of my story that kid landed in
California two weeks ago and he's in IOP
sober living changing his life
foreign
going on and on about the testimonies of
sobriety that I
there's an individual
a good friend of mine we got high
together Wellington
because of my story he says I Inspire
him somehow
he's been in the same rehab
for two months that I went through
I guess my uncle was right God did have
a plan for me when he went to go visit
me
a wise man John once told me
if you've never been a mess you don't
have any message
you do know I have been a mess from the
stories I've told you
because of sobriety I do have a message
my message is if
if I can do it
you can as well
You are not alone I know that feeling
letting go of your morals
waking up sick as a dog hopeless
having to go still for that next fix
I've been there
You Are Not Alone
I don't have the answers to all the
drug problems but I do know there's a
solution
pick up that phone call
I don't know there's detoxes everywhere
start with that and just know that your
ways does not work take direction from
someone else
I'm an immigrant from Cape Verde
I was strung out on fentanyl
if I can do it you can as well
I'm a living testimony to sobriety
today me and my ex-wife have a
phenomenal relationship we co-parent
phenomenally
that's the one woman in my addiction I
wanted to hit her with a car
my son thinks I'm cooler than Spider-Man
that's sobriety
I'll end with that you are not alone
love is love thank you
magnificent
such guitar